[Inaudible].
I'm going to ask you a question and please be honest.
Have you ever heard of Oman?
You probably know that it is an oil rich country in the middle East,
but have you ever seen a story about it on the news? Cause I bet you haven't.
And this is surprising given that there was a huge news event for this country
at the beginning of 2020 checklists.
[Inaudible].
Amman Sultan Qaboos spin site has died. State media reports,
the associated press 2020, the CELTA.
Had been ruling this country for more than 50 years.
And given that this country as an absolute monarchy,
the death of the Sultan spells a complete political change,
but that is not all the new Sultan he found.
Ben Tariq has inherited a country that was destined to be in the news all the
time. Have you ever heard of the Strait of Hormuz?
This is one of the most important waterways in the world at shipping lane is
only three kilometers white. Yeah.
Every day over 18 million barrels of oil pass through it from the East to the
West.
[Inaudible].
How about one third of all the oil transported by sea travels through this
passage, this street is guarded by two countries,
Iran and Aman guarding it as a huge responsibility.
And now combine that fact with the knowledge that on the other side of the
street is Iran,
a rising regional power antagonistic to the West and looming on Oman's Northern
border is Saudi Arabia, the other pro Western regional power. Oh,
and they also share a border with Yemen, a country embroiled in a civil war.
This makes for a highly volatile situation and which stuff.
[Inaudible].
Iran, seizes, British tanker in Strait of Hormuz as tensions Mount France,
24, 2019.
At this point,
I'm sure many of you are surprised that hardly anyone could name omens capital
by the way, it's Muscat,
but let's leave geography aside for a minute because we haven't seen the whole
picture or man's political system just like its neighbors,
religion and politics are very closely related and Oman,
despite being surrounded by extreme theocracies,
Oman is surprisingly modern and tolerant, for example, whereas in Saudi Arabia,
policemen,
let girls burn to death in a school fire to avoid them breaking local law.
By being outside with insufficient covering in, or man,
it is actually not allowed for women to wear an,
a Cabot while working in professional institutes or driving and Oman women
received the right to vote along with everyone else in 2002,
while in Saudi Arabia,
women gained the right to vote long after their male counterparts in 2015.
So despite all of this Oman is still completely under the radar and this is not
by chance.
Previous Salton went to great lengths to make sure his country would maintain
friendly ties with everyone.
So a man has managed to stay away from any conflict.
In a way we could say is the Switzerland of the Saudi peninsula,
except that they are not as rich. In fact, Oman is just a middle income country,
which makes them the second poorest country and this oil rich region.
So now the question is what challenges will a new Salton face?
What is going on in this country? How can it be such an important enclave yet?
We almost never hear anything about it today.
We are going to answer all of these questions, but before we do, as always,
let's look at some history.
The.
Fifth wheel of Islam.
Let's discuss middle Eastern politics.
You must first understand its religious divides. You see,
there are two major branches of Islam. The most popular goal is Sunni Islam,
almost all the Muslim majority nations belong to this brunch.
Then we have Shia Islam, which makes up the majority in four countries, Iran,
Iraq, Azerbaijan, and Bahrain. As you knew,
the relations between Sunni Islam and Shia Islam are far from friendly.
The cold war between Saudi Arabia and Iran is rooted in this religious.
Rivalry.
There is one nation that is neither Shia nor Sunni and yes,
not nation is Oman. Oman's majority. Religion is known as I Buddhism.
This is important because you see Sunni's and she is,
tend to view all others as heretics or infidels,
even resorting to killing each other on occasion. What's more Saudi Arabia.
One of the regional powers is Sunni and Iran. Another power is Shia.
This creates another rift in the middle East,
and I'll use these two powers to use religion as a tool to promote their
interests. For example, around supporting the Shia,
who Thies and Yemen and Saudi Arabia supporting Sunni terrorists in Syria.
This is important because Oman's a body majority inoculates the countries from
either sides, extreme religious arguments,
also both Shia and Sunni Muslims believe that the Muslim world requires a
central authority. Thus,
they want to expand their religious influence worldwide.
I Buddhism in contrast has no expansionist belief that gives omen a level of
political protection from the wider conflict. Additionally,
Oman can be defined by two major doctrines conservatism and.
British.
The servers of Omani rule in East Africa commented that it bodies were the least
fanatic and sectarian of all Muslims and openly associated with people of all
faiths and pray together with Sunni Muslims.
Hostile action is reserved for one type of person,
the unjust ruler who refuses to mend his ways or relinquish his power.
Valerie Hoffman, professor of Islamic studies, university of Illinois.
Many Sunni's who take a convert or dying approach. It.
Bodies are unlikely to attack those who they view as Kfar or sinners for instead
to take a stance of ostracization and social isolation.
This is definitely a long way from being completely tolerant and open-minded,
but still it is better to be ostracized than killed.
So I know what you're thinking.
We said the eye Buddism is defined by tolerance as well as conservatism.
How is it possible to mix those two? Make no mistake.
Oman is not aggressive towards non-believers,
but that doesn't mean they have been particularly modern. In fact,
during most of the 20th century,
Oman has been the most backward country in the whole Arabian peninsula.
They were so attached to tradition that for a long time,
modern things like umbrellas and sunglasses were forbidden.
How is that possible? Let's take a look.
Better late than.
Never in 1932. So he'd been timer inherited the Sultan,
Nate of Muscat and Oman as the country was known at that time. Now,
when timer was younger,
his father made sure new un-Islamic ideas would influence his education or
philosophy.
His father was successful and that he created someone who was a very traditional
and conservative Muslim. In fact.
Maybe two.
That's me for one moment. As I list some of the things that he band music,
movies, singing, dancing, photography, newspapers, electricity, flashlights,
umbrellas, and Western dress, including the sunglasses. Yes,
you heard that correctly.
And one of the sunniest places on earth sunglasses were forbidden.
Even writing bicycles required a permit and anyone wanting to travel abroad had
to obtain the Sultan's personal permission regarding bad health habits.
Oman had a hardcore take as well. Smoking was punishable by flogging.
That's another country that I could never go to.
Another reason this country stayed locked in its traditions is the oil wasn't
found in, or man until 1962 is almost 25 years after Saudi Arabia.
All of this.
Explain why your man is still not as rich as its neighbors,
but if all this weren't enough, the country has also suffered two,
several Wars in less than two decades. That's rape or man has injured,
not one but two civil Wars.
I bet you are no wondering how it is possible that you've never heard of this
country before. Right? Everything started back in 1951 that year,
all minded lost its British protectorate status,
making it a proper independent nation,
but the Brits were not willing to seek control of this country so easily.
Even if oil hadn't actually been discovered yet,
it was known that the country had undiscovered oil beds.
And this explains the UK is full support through the previous ultra conservative
cell phone.
But nevertheless allowed British petroleum alongside other oil companies to
undertake exploration. This supports would be very important.
Three years later in 1954,
some regions in the internal part of omen backed by Saudi Arabia and Egypt
rebelled against the CELTA. This is how the Jebel act our war
That lasted until 1959.
Of course the Sultan ultimately won the war with the support of the UK army,
but peace didn't last long in Oman,
four years after the first civil war had finished,
another one started this time.
It was a Marxist rebellion in the South of the country. And this case,
the Marxist rebels wanted Delphi, a Southern region to be independent.
They were banked by China, the USSR and the Arab socialist parties.
This time,
the UK and Iran helped us all turn over money to defeat the insurgents. Yes,
I did just say a run in the UK or fighting site by site in the same war.
Remember that this was the 1960s back then Iran was ruled by the shock of
Perisher and was an ally of the West during this war more than 700 arena and
soldiers died fighting the communists.
And this explains why Oman still maintains friendly ties with Iran today.
Also fun authoritarian facts.
The Sultan became paranoid during these rebellions and actually banned
conversations lasting longer than 15 minutes.
As you can imagine that you can't, wasn't really.
Supporting a leader like that.
Putting aside the ethical dilemmas of supporting such an authoritarian ruler,
there was a pragmatic issue too. After all we're talking about with rents,
supporting a fanatic who can't even maintain stability within his country is
bonnet for business. So in 1978, there was another uprising against the Sultan.
Only this time,
it was a bloodless coup d'etat supported by the British themselves.
So you could say, but the UK Poot side has been timer and to power.
And the UK got rid of them when they had enough.
His successor was the man that you see in this picture.
Robin has been Saeed was the son of the previous Sultan, but unlike his father,
he had a Western upbringing.
He was educated in the UK and had served in the British military.
When he took over, he was only 29 years old under this new cell ton,
a brand new country will be born.
He rolled back all of his father's absurd buns and the same year he took power.
He abolished slavery,
making Oman the second to last nation and the world to do so. I mean,
I guess it's better late than never. And now I know what you're thinking.
So which country was the last one? And the answer is more tenia.
The only abolish slavery in 1981, 1981,
but let's get back to our story.
It was in such bad shape before the new Sultan that the infant mortality rate
was 75%. Malnutrition was widespread. There were only three schools.
The literacy rate was 5% and there were only 10 kilometers,
a six miles of paved routes. Now 50 years later,
Oman as a totally different country,
umbrellas and sunglasses are legal and homosexuality is only punishable by
three years in prison. I say only because by our standards,
that's actually a very progressive policy and that's not all women make up our
own one third of the workforce and apostasy isn't even technically illegal,
which again is nice considering literally every country surrounding omen
executes. Those who renounced religion onto that.
And the old man's literacy rate is now a healthy 95
In economic terms,
when the new Sultan came to power Oman's GDP per capita was $354 in
today's money. Currently Oman's GDP is $16,400.
That's really about improvement. Although it's not really impressive.
If we compare it with the other Arab countries,
it's still a lot lower than the Saudis, $23,400 and way lower than guitars.
$69,000 making Oman the second poorest country in the peninsula only beating
Yemen and wealth. Of course,
this can be explained by the fact that Oman started his rags-to-riches tale much
later than the other Arab countries.
Generally speaking,
we can say that the new Sultan has been a reasonably good leader for this
country, although it wasn't really hard to improve on what his father has done.
Now, the question is, what can we expect for from his son? Let's take a look.
A Western friend in the East.
You may be forgiven for thinking that the United States and Saudi Arabia have
always been allies, but this friendship hasn't always been that clear.
During most of the 20th century,
the Saudis were frenemies with a U S happily selling them oil,
but also constantly clashing with America's greatest ally Israel and funding
anti-Western terrorist organization.
In the meantime.
Well, mine was happy to just be friends with the West. In fact,
Oman was never at war with Israel and we're always on the cutting edge of Arab
has really diplomacy even allowed the U S to put military bases on their soil
before it became a trend.
And this way Oman is sort of the hipster of the Arab world,
but it is not just the U S that Amanda's friendly with them.
This Iran,
Oman stress expansion of bilateral ties, Meryl news agency,
2020 that's right.
Oman is actually one of the country's friendliest to run in the region.
Do you remember that Marxist guerrilla conflict from the 1960s,
the cell town continued to honor the memory of the 700 Iranian soldiers who died
in order to stabilize his country. Since then,
Oman has maintained a good relationship with a run.
Even after the revolution of 1979,
they have even performed some limited Naval military exercises.
[Inaudible].
But make no mistake.
This is not just a matter of loyalty or Munn knows where it stands on the map
they're located. And one of the most critical enclaves for world's trades,
they are neighbors with Saudi Arabia, but they are not far from Iran either.
So Oman cleverly follows a strategy of avoiding making enemies and test the
policy of the enemy of my friend can still be my friend going as far as to
keep close relations with both Iran and Iraq in the.
I there Warren.
It's all parts of a cunning strategy. You see,
Oman is a relatively small country and an incredibly important location,
surrounded by beggar and wealthier powers.
All of them would want to dominate women if it weren't for the fact that Oman
makes sure it stays in everyone's good books. For example,
many Gulf States isolated Qatar in 2017,
Qatar was also friendly with many groups, such as the Muslim brotherhood,
as well as many other terrorist organizations.
The straw was when guitar.
Started supporting Pru Iranian groups at this point,
Saudi Arabia and its allies made a trade embargo against guitar.
And you may be wondering, so why didn't they do this with Oman?
The answer is the Oman didn't support any terrorists or any armed group.
They just kept good ties with everybody,
but without trying to play any significant, GeoBlue
Another great example of this little profile diplomacy is the Yemeni civil war.
Yemen shares a border with Oman,
but instead of supporting either of the two contenders in this war,
women is just securing as border and supplying humanitarian aid. I mean,
really every country in the region was like Oman.
The middle East would be a peaceful place.
And Oman achieves more with these friendly relations with our allies rivals than
just acting on cynical power. Please, Oman is an important diplomatic hub.
For example, the joint comprehensive plan of action. AKA,
the Iran nuclear deal was negotiated in Oman.
This explains why Oman rarely appears on the news.
And when it does is for things like this.
Amman foot's $1 million bail to free us hikers to American hikers who had been
jailed in Iran for over two years were released on Sunday after the Sultan of
Oman paid there, $1 million bail,
Salton caboose inside also paid for the release of a third American hiker,
Sarah shroud last year, the Atlantic 2011, but all of this.
Was the work of Sultan. Qaboos the new Sultan Mr. High theme,
Ben Tariq has inherited a much richer and more modern country that has friendly
ties with all.
[Inaudible].
No, you make, think that everything seems bright for this oil rich country,
right? The new self-tan can just sit tight and watch this oil revenue Roland as
citizens becoming happier and richer and keeping out of international news
headlines. Right? Well,
far from it as so often happens with all the countries in this region.
Oman is extremely reliant on oil,
more than 80% of the government's revenue just comes from this sweet,
sweet dinosaur juice. And this is one hell of a problem.
When oil markets go down, which is exactly what has happened.
No.
2014 Oil prices have tank and this trend has become even more
dire during the coronavirus crisis. Basically,
if a man doesn't want to go back to being a poor country,
there is only one thing that they can do diversify.
This is what will man 2040 plan hopes to achieve just like Saudi Arabia or the
United Arab Emirates. Well,
man is trying to focus on high-tech manufacturing and tourism.
More specifically, they are trying to attract Indian tourism.
They have even started to build a brand new high-tech city called D U Q M,
which is a weird name for a setting. Ideally,
this city could become the new Dubai,
but it's still too soon to see if this project will be a success.
[Inaudible].
They're beginning to run out of capital.
Their 2020 debts to GDP ratio is around 60% and rising fast,
but the pain doesn't end there in June of 2020,
Moody's downgraded or man sovereignty rating for the second team and a year down
to a non-investment junk level and Oman bodily needs investment to make its
diversification strategy work.
It seems mine is in a rut for the team being unable to make money from its oil
that desperately needs to encourage investors to fund his projects faced with
this situation. Well,
mine's modernization blitz has been put on hold and when it can resume it's
anyone's guess this coupled with a new Salton who's rained for less than a year
makes Oman's future uncertain.
So no, the question is will the new Salton managed to really diversify Oman?
Well, he continued making Oman the most tolerant country on the Arab peninsula.
Well, all mine managed to catch up with its other wealthy neighbors.
So as always,
we leave it to you guys to leave your comments in the section below.
Also don't forget that we publish brand new videos every week.
So subscribe to visual politics and hit that bell button.
So you won't miss any posts. Also please visit our friends,
reconsider media.com.
The podcast that provided the vocals in this episode are not my dulcet tunes.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs up. And if he doesn't, I mean,
well give us a thumbs up anyway. Also we do have a Patrion scheme.
So look to that. If you're interested, have a good one. And as always,
I'll see you guys next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.
Yeah.